[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
50 years ago tonight the television
series mash premiered on cbs during its
11 season run mash received over a
hundred emmy nominations the series
finale was seen by almost 122 million
viewers a record outside super bowls
that still stands
leading the cast was alan aldis dr
benjamin franklin hawkeye pierce in
addition to being an actor writer and
director all is also a best-selling
author and fierce advocate for science
communication
now 86 years old and he says as active
as ever
alda sat down with us at stony brook
university on long island
my life has been improvisational i'm
always interested in other actors or
writers or directors who
talk about the plan they have
for the next five years what's the point
of it because life is going to come up
with its own plan
alan aldo's improvisational approach to
life
brought him to acting at a young age
don't try to bully me dad i feel i have
something to say as an artist
take my woman with grapes for instance
it also eventually brought him
unprecedented acclaim uh finest kind
just like mother used to make for anyone
born before about 1970
mash needs no explanation
[Music]
for those who may have missed it
it was set during the korean war and
told the story of the doctors nurses and
staff
of the
4077th mobile army surgical hospital
we've all had 12 straight hours of
meatball surgery in there my brain is
sending me urgent rest telegrams
by the time the show ended in 1983
alan alda was a 47 year old living
legend having become the only person
ever to win emmys for acting
directing and writing writing directing
acting is there one thing that you
preferred or prefer more no they each
has its own pleasure and acting has an
ecstasy to it that one's doing it's
going well
you're you're floating in the air yeah
so it's a really terrific feeling
dangerous feeling too i guess well i
guess it can be one of the things that i
got out of improvisation was the idea
that if anything goes wrong that's just
a door to open
i just like to poke around
perhaps no better example of that
is the near-death experience aldehyde
while shooting in a remote region of
chile during his time hosting scientific
american frontiers on pbs
alda suffered a serious intestinal
blockage and was rushed to a local
hospital
surviving the experience left him
feeling reborn
and he focused his new energy on
expanding the field of communication in
science when we started working on
helping scientists communicate better i
thought that the big service we would be
performing was
scientists to be able to communicate
with the public and it turned out that
communicating with one another is just
as important
it's not a curse to have knowledge it's
a curse to think that what knowledge you
have is possessed by other people as
well everybody doesn't know what you
know in the detail that you know it
how do you tell them
you know we don't tell people things so
much we don't give tips we don't give
hints
we put people through an experience
in 2009 old established the first
program in the country that teaches the
alda method
at stony brook university in new york
and
learned about
love it includes plenty of improvisation
when she laughs she's not laughing
even at 86 and trying hard to avoid
covid he couldn't help but jump in on a
recent training session we attended
the first he's been to since the
pandemic began you make the person or
the people you're talking to
a communication partner
not the target of your lecture it's
tough because every people want to
lecture but i think it has to be a more
dynamic relationship i think you're
right well you seem to do it i don't
mean to get too personal with you before
i know you're better
but
from the time we sat down together you
were
talking to me and you were you i saw you
looking at my reaction all the scared 19
years ago wouldn't be the only medical
issue he's turned into a public point of
conversation i was diagnosed three and a
half years ago
in july 2018 he announced he had
parkinson's
accompanied by a video on twitter
showing himself juggling one of the
reasons i came out
when i did was i wanted people to know
that
you can still function
and it's the earlier you get
into an exercise program
the better it is because the symptoms
are progressive
so i wanted to help demystify it i mean
look i'm i'm i'm as active as i've ever
been so i so i shake a little i just
still act
you should really have a passcode on
this
it's my small rebellion against modern
life he acts
and podcasts i'm alan alder and this is
clear and vivid clear and vivid now
includes more than 220 conversations i
didn't invent stereoscopy but i invented
this viewer where does the push come
from
to keep working that hard to stay that
involved whether it's the podcast
whether it's acting whether it's doing
this
whatever else
at the stage in life that you're at
well i don't know how else to know i'm
alive i mean it also includes taking a
break
and saying oh this is great i'm on
vacation for the next 20 minutes i'm not
going to
do anything important i'm going to have
fun with this game on the computer
when i was 16 i thought
here's the answer to life
moderation in all things
especially moderation
very good very good i like that i've
never heard that before and i thought of
it at 16. yes
i love that i could walk into that mess
tent order lunch
start naked nobody would pay any
attention to me alda still keeps the
boots he wore for all 11 seasons of mash
which he gainfully agreed to bring to
our interview do you know how much those
boots are worth they're not worth that
much i don't think i tried to auction
them off for charity
did you really yeah and i couldn't get
the base price so i kept them okay
maybe not maybe now we can see how
really swell they are
i can auction them off for the center
for communicating science and get a
fortune
do you still put them on
no i haven't put them on and since the
show ended
for the most part
for the last half century
alan olda has spent very little time
stepping back
into nostalgia
does it feel like it's been 50 years or
does it feel like a lot less than that
it feels like a really long time ago it
feels like it happened to somebody else
but fortunately he lets me live in his
house
[Laughter]
if you see a rerun on tv now
do you watch no i haven't seen a whole
show in years
i hear it's very good
it was excellent it was excellent one of
my favorites great job jeff 50 years ago
tonight yeah
um he was a joy to spend time with so we
thank him and we thank stony brook for
hosting us you know he
gives so much to so many charities i had
the
pleasure of meeting him at one
and he is just so full of life and
sharing and so it's so great to to
witness your conversation moderation in
all things moderation and all things
especially moderation i love it